[Musique]
bonsoir dr weiss
alors la question que les gens dans la
grande région de montréal se posent ils
vont se poser au cours des prochains
jours c est ce que avec d'une part des
hôpitaux qui commence
on parle de l'est de la ville là c'est
difficile maisonneuve rosemont qui
commence à être débordé et des quartiers
où les choses semblent pas aller dans la
bonne direction comme montréal nord est
ce qu'on pourra vraiment commencer à
débloquer hilla ville qu'en pensez vous
en êtes là dessus mais c'est sûr qu'il
faut avoir toutes les données en main
c'est un des confinement qui vaille
progressif très très je dirais lent à
très petite dose et il faut pas avoir
peur de revenir en arrière
bon qu'est ce qu'on à montréal
actuellement on a encore beaucoup de cas
on sait qu'on en a probablement encore
plus parce qu'on ne teste pas beaucoup
dans la communauté
donc si vous êtes quelqu'un de
relativement jeunes en bonne santé sans
facteur de risque
avec maladie qui ressemble aux convives
19 mais pas très sévère envoûté sera pas
donc le nombre de cas à montréal et
probablement et certainement beaucoup
plus grand que ce qui est officiellement
rapporté donc les cas qui sont
officiellement testé positif ça c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose on sait qu'on a des
hôpitaux et on est une espèce dark the
big o qui vont du lakeshore dans l'ouest
en passant par sacré-coeur santa cabrini
maison sève qui sont finalement des
hôpitaux qui sont actuellement aux
prises avec la transmission nosocomiale
de kobe de disney's donc à l'intérieur
des hôpitaux on sait que cette
transmission là et on sait qu'il ya des
ondes de montréal sont des ondes très
chaude et mc allen emprunter public la
directrice de la santé publique et
marianne docteur droit a très très bien
expliquer le phénomène en disant qu'ils
avaient des quartiers où la santé
publique essayer de comprendre la
dynamique peut-être des gens qui
travaillent beaucoup dans le milieu de
la santé des gens aussi qui travaillent
dans des environnements sont pas faciles
puis aussi dans une zone de montréal qui
est une zone défavorisée avec une
densité de population qui était élevé
donc tout ça mis ensemble ça fait qu'il
ya des zones qui sont plus à risque
d'autres entre guillemets d'exploser
vous rappeler qu'au début
c'était beaucoup la zone du centre ouest
de marianne qui était la plus affectée
cette zone là est devenu beaucoup plus
froides maintenant sinon qui est plus au
contrôle et on dirait que le phénomène
s'est déplacé vers le nord et vers l'est
de la ville donc tout ça pour dire que
montréal yves rolland surveiller
d'épidémiologie de façon extrêmement
importante
surtout quand on va commencer un certain
déconfinement faut pas oublier non plus
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent à
montréal de la grande région de montréal
travailler et donc si on commence à
avoir un problème à montréal ces gens-là
prouvait des vecteurs pour ramener le
virus dans leur environnement
donc on verra on verra si le 11 mai le
19 mai nous sommes collectivement prêt
ou pas la voyez tout à fait mais c'est
surtout on va le voir au début du mois
de juin dans quand on va commencer
disons que tout se passe relativement
bien et que le nombre de cas actuel
reste stable et qu'on a pas de
catastrophe dans les hôpitaux et qu'on
arrive plus ou moins à contrôler
certaines des éclosions dans un commun
dans les hôpitaux
là on va d confinée autour du 11 mai
qu'est ce qui va se passer deux semaines
plus tard c'est là où on va commencer à
voir une réponse bien plus claires dont
vous avez dit quelque chose d'important
c'est qu'actuellement on ne teste pas
les gens qui sont par exemple en plein
de santé qui ont 50 ha qui ont des
légers symptômes
ici on le faisait on pourrait dénicher
débusquer des camps un peu partout or
encore aujourd'hui en conférence de
presse le docteur arruda dit on souhaite
pas assez de 6000 thèse par jour à 14000
thèse par jour au québec de demain ray
expliquez nous pourquoi c'est si
important surtout quand ont des
consignes de tester beaucoup c'est parce
qu'il faut avoir une bonne idée claire
de l'épidémie imaginez vous que demain
on recommence l'école puis cueillez dans
une classe deux enfants qui sont un peu
malade et on pense qu'ils ont la copie
est que pour une raison x y voulait
tester et que les deux reviennent
positive et là vous dis est ce qu'on
devrait tester on va dire les 12 autres
élèves qui étaient dans la classe en
même temps eux et vous testez les deux
autres élèves et on sait que chez des
enfants beaucoup peuvent être
asymptomatique et il y en a 10 sur 12
qui reviennent positiver quand aucun
symptôme mais on sait qu'il ya une
transmission importante à ce moment là
dans cette école là dans cette classe là
parce que ces douze élèves là
probablement des contacts à la maison
ils ont des contacts dans l'école danse
est un ensemble de facteurs de la même
façon on doit tester aussi au niveau du
personnel de santé parce qu'on veut
savoir si le personnel de santé a été
infectée ou pas dans certaines
circonstances on veut aussi tester des
gens éventuellement dans certaines
conditions est ce qu'on devrait comme
par exemple à new york tester toutes les
femmes enceintes qui vont marcher parce
qu'on sait qu'à new york à une
proportion non négligeable de femmes
enceintes qui accouchent qui sont
asymptomatiques mais positive
donc lorsque ces gens ces femmes là vont
arriver pour accoucher à l'hôpital même
si elles ne font pas de symptômes même
si elles n'ont pas de facteur de risque
est-ce qu on les isole d'emblée comme si
elle avait un kobe tu disais ça pour pas
justement qu'elle contamine d'autres
personnes dont le test va nous permettre
d'avoir beaucoup de facilités à gérer
des éclosions imaginez que demain on
déconfit nisine il ya 100 travailleurs
dans l'usiné est un indice qui tombent
malades
on veut savoir combien parmi les autres
sont possiblement infecté était ce qu'on
fait avec eux pour leur série pardonnez
ma pour les retirer
alors là il va falloir voir qu'est ce
qu'on veut faire il va falloir aller au
cas par cas
est ce qu'on va mettre par exemple un
max est-ce qu'on va les retirer ça
dépend et là il va falloir jouer au cas
par cas et à un moment donné si vous
n'avez pas juste une mais deux mais
trois mais quatre mais cinq usines dans
une région vous commencez à avoir des
cas alors là il va falloir penser à
l'aspect dur confinement peut-être pour
cette région
donc c'est pour ça que c'est un
phénomène dynamique alors là les tests
donc on a fait la détection du virus
complet aux tests sérologiques s'en
viennent avec des limites on en a déjà
parlé mais les deux ensemble on nous
permet de comprendre la dynamique de
l'épidémiologie de la comique 19 au
québec
bon ben parlons-en des tests
sérologiques parce que vous le
mentionnez c'est important et ça va
devenir important ça sera une manière un
devoir qu'il a eue qui a qui a développé
l'infection et qui est entre guillemets
protéger tout à fait c'est ça qu'on veut
faire on veut exactement faire ce genre
de choses mais pour savoir qui est déjà
une infection qui est protégé il ya des
limites avec ces tests sérologiques on
est aux balbutiements né dans la
première génération des tests donc il va
y avoir une deuxième troisième quatrième
on va avoir des tests beaucoup plus
sophistiqué des tests du monde et etc
des anticorps de lakovic 19 et non pas
des autres coronavirus de façon je
dirais croisés il déteste aussi qu'on en
espère détecter ce qu'on appelle des
anticorps neutralisants c'est à dire des
anticorps qui disent non seulement vous
avez des anticorps mais vous avez les
bons anticorps pour ne pas rattraper le
microbe bons intervalles je vous posais
la question tout début il ya mille ans
qu'on a commencé à faire ses interviews
qu'est ce que vous avez appris récemment
que vous ne sachiez que saviez pas au
sujet du virus est ce que depuis quoi
quelques jours quelques semaines il ya
des choses qui vous semblent de plus en
plus clair et qui est un élément nouveau
qu'on ne connaissait pas oui tout à fait
alors il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
nouvelles par exemple on sait que le
virus est de plus en plus athérogène
donc c'est un virus qui crée beaucoup de
cailloux
on l'a vu chez des enfants l'a vu chez
des jeunes adultes par exemple qui donne
des accidents vasculaires cérébraux
on le voit aussi chez de plus en plus de
gens qui ont des embolies pulmonaires
dont il ya un ensemble de gens qui nous
de patients chez qui on découvre
beaucoup de créations de caillots et ce
virus semblait très hétérogène bon alors
ça c'est une chose on a j'ai appris vous
savez beaucoup de choses finalement on
n'a pas beaucoup de choses sur la
transmission du virus en apprend des
choses aussi sur les nouveaux
médicaments lesquels peut être en plus
d'espoir que dont on a vu qu'un
médicament leur m d'ici lire apporte
peut-être un peu plus d'espoir que
d'autres médicaments il faut comprendre
que ce n'est pas un médicament qui a été
fait pour lakovic 19 c'est un médicament
qui était déjà existants qu'on a testé
qu'on a sorti du tiroir mais qui semble
avoir une certaine efficacité
donc ça c'est une deuxième chose on
commence à avoir un peu une meilleure
compréhension pourquoi la torride 19
finalement attaque les poumons et
pourquoi il ya des gens qui ont
peut-être des jeux d'hier et des
réponses immunitaires beaucoup plus
sévère que d'autres pourquoi et du un
respect qui est dû à un récepteur au
niveau de certaines cellules qu'on a
dans notre poumon et qui fait que ces
cellules a probablement lorsqu'il ya des
gens qui ont beaucoup de ces récepteurs
là vont développer entre guillemets une
maladie peut-être un peu plus sévère bon
mais fierons on va finir par en venir à
bout
est-ce que sur la scène internationale
sur la sueur
la séquence des cas ailleurs dans le
monde est ce qu'il ya des choses qui
vous ont frappé depuis quelques semaines
sur ce point l'allemagne sur l'asie sur
ailleurs bon alors devancé le problème
qu'on a c'est que tous les pays n'ont
pas la même fiabilité dans ce qu'il nous
apporte évidemment
alors il ya des pays où on sait on sait
très bien que le nombre de cas qui est
rapporté ou la façon dont les 10000 e j
la courbe épidémiologique n'a pas
beaucoup de sens alors il faut vraiment
se tourner vers des pays qui sont
fiables en termes de rapporter les cas
est ce qu'on s'aperçoit pas vous et les
gros pays européens ont peu à peu près
la même épidémiologie a quasiment le
même nombre de décès entre grosso modo
entre l'espagne l'italie la france et la
grande-bretagne l'allemagne est un peu
différente on en a déjà parlé
est-ce que l'allemagne est en train
peut-être de rentrer dans une zone un
peu de déconfinement actuellement et on
voit que des pays qui ont très bien
réussi comme on en a déjà parlé la
nouvelle zélande australie le singapour
singapour par contre il ya un gros
problème actuellement
vous savez il ya beaucoup de
travailleurs migrants qui vivent dans
des cités dortoirs et à singapour le
nombre de cas a explosé dans ce dans ce
groupe là donc on ce qui par contre est
claire là c'est que tout le monde va
être extrêmement frileux avant de
réouvrir toutes les frontières
je pense pour morrow réouvrira pas de
frontières de façon rapide à peu près
partout sur la planète
parce que les jambes repas encore le
contrôle de l'économie et il n'y a pas
de manuels sur la colline 19
voilà dr calvin est toujours un plaisir
merci
on se revoit lundi en ce qui me concerne
merci beaucoup de faire sens pour nous
c'est très apprécié de tous
un peu plaisir bonne soirée noire